anthony on poursuit avec le sport et on
va parler du cyclisme sans transition un
cyclisme j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure de
raymond poulidor qui sort son livre sur
ces 50 premier tour de france j'ai eu la
chance de le rencontrer la semaine
dernière contre dernier aussi écrit ça
compte des laisses accessoirement donc
j'ai eu la chance de le rencontrer la
semaine dernière à bois d'arcy il
faisait une dédicace de son de son livre
images réalisées avec patrick jacques de
dixmude je suis à côté d'un grand nom du
cyclisme qui a fait rêver tant de
français pendant ces 14 tours monsieur
poulidor bonjour bonjour vous venez donc
de sortir un livre sur vos 50 premier
tour de france première question
pourquoi avoir écrit ce livre
mais michel kahn tour de france qu'il
faut ensuite à trois autres que j'avais
écrit en collaboration avec jean paul
brouchon on a eu l'idée cette année j'ai
en comprimant 50e tour de france 14
comme coureur le reste
radio télévision et maintenant caravane
publicitaire depuis deux ans avec elle
c'est elle qui patronnent le maillot
jaune
on a eu cette idée de raconter ses 50
tour de france
les quatorze bien sûr comme coureur et
puis le reste tu es radio télévision et
maintenant comme je vous dis dans la
caravane publicitaire est alors
justement par rapport à ces 50 tours il
ya sûrement des grands souvenirs des
grandes et grands tours même des
éditions qui vous ont marqué en temps
coureurs parce que quatorze éditions
temps coureur et ensuite dans la
caravane comme vous le disiez ce qui est
une étape
un tour qui vous a marqué
particulièrement où il y en a plusieurs
il ya déjà mon premier tour 1962 j'ai
pris le départ nancy place stanislas
avec l'avant-bras gauche dans le plâtre
les dix premiers jours c'est un calvaire
vous ne demandez une tour qui m'ont
marqué et évidemment 64 on évoque un ce
fameux duel avec anquetil
pratiquement le dernier jour il ya le
puy-de-dôme évidemment qui revient à
l'esprit qui a fait la photo a fait le
tour du monde
ce fameux coude à coude et puis cette
dernière étape versailles par ibn parc
des princes ou à deux kilomètres de
l'arrivée
on savait pas encore si elle qui allait
gagner le tour de france
et puis il ya l'autre 64 14 c'est à dire
dix ans après j'ai fait un nouveau duel
avec eddy merckx ou gelée lâché à
plusieurs reprises dans la montagne
j'ai gagné une grande étape à saint lary
soulan dans les pyrénées puis j'ai fait
2e à nouveau dix ans après le duel avec
jacky et vous parler du duel avec
jacques ont-ils on ne peut pas nommer
raymond poulidor sans parler de cet
éternel deuxième place ça vous colle
encore à la peau aujourd'hui à bassam au
col plus qu'à la peau d'ailleurs si je
suis là aujourd'hui si on parle de
poulidor mon dernier tour monde quand
même 1 76 si on parle encore de poulidor
c'est grâce à sa deuxième place je me
pose beaucoup beaucoup la question et si
j'avais gagné 2,3 tour de france deux
supporters me disent que j'aurais dû
même tous les gagner je crois que je ne
l'aurais pas cette popularité que j'ai
aujourd'hui
dans votre livre aussi vous parler des
rencontres que vous avez pu faire
notamment un monsieur qui a raconté que
c'était le plus beau jour de sa vie de
vous avoir rencontré explique-t-il un
petit peu cette cette rencontre il ya
des rencontres énorme je fais des
rencontres terrible je me souviens une
fois je m'étais arrêté pour satisfaire
un petit besoin naturel une pause
sanitaires comme il y avait personne
j'étais dans une forêt et à une personne
âgée qui était assis à l'ombre il
faisait très chaud et qui m'a vu arriver
qui s'est mis à pleurer
il était seul et il croyait pas ses yeux
et je suis arrivé il m'a salué
tout en pleurs il a dit maintenant je
peux mourir tranquille c'est quelque
chose d'énorme de poignant vous savez on
a pleuré pratiquement tous les deux et
dans ce livre aussi vous dresser le
portrait de bernard hinault de lance
armstrong
on ne peut pas évoquer le cyclisme en
ensemençant parlé de lance amstrong
comment vous avez juger ses performances
à l'époque sur le tour je juger ses
performances
j'ai vu évoluer armstrong super
professionnel
d'ailleurs cette année lorsque j'ai vu
le comportement de l'équipe sky
celui qui a gagné oui les mêmes méthodes
comme ça le professionnalisme sur le
bout des doigts
rien ne lui échappe j'ai vu encore
aujourd'hui nous consacre un article sur
l'équipe où c'est les accusations sont
énormes à mort à cette situation il rien
de nouveau y a rien de nouveau
tout ce qu'on a écrit aujourd'hui on le
savait jusqu'à preuve de contraire
armstrong a subi énormément de contrôler
tous négative prise de sang et autres en
ce moment là j'en déduis que tout le
monde ses adversaires étaient au même
point il a été négative les contrôles
n'étaient peut-être pas au point on ne
pouvait pas déceler ces médicaments est
hôte qui soit disant il a pris dans les
preuves sont là qui les aurait prise
mais il a été négative et joua pas
pourquoi nous a livré 15 ans après c'est
tour de france où il a pu quand même
pris des risques énormes mais
quelquefois ça ça vire un jeu bon mais
c'est comme ça merci beaucoup et rennes
ont tenté de nous avoir accordé quelques
minutes pour tv films pour cette
interview exclusive
oui tout à fait évident exclusive à
porter mes fils